[Musique]
nous sommes au salon de l'auto de
montréal ne peuvent faire goûter à 50
personnes une collation incontournable
pour la boutique la plupart des
fromageries en produisent on la retrouve
partout où on va de l'essence il s'agit
du fromage qui fait c'qui quick
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui selon vous explique que ça
fasse squeak ce week end est pour moi un
bon fromage en grains bien réussi c'est
vraiment pas ça passe par la texture des
chocs ne qu'on appelle squeak strict
l'horizon c'est vraiment ce qu'ils vont
faire la différence lorsqu'on prend on
va sentir sur le die beau comme un peu
glissé que le fromage et en coffret donc
encore un peu humide aussi c'est cet
expert d'expérience le sensoriel là je
fais en sorte que le fromage en grève à
une meilleure d'une place alors nous
dommage
ces nocturnes à sandton en bonne
compagnie
la chute au départ
on n'arrête pas la peine enfin dans le
pays de celui qui le fait on l'achète on
le mange peut-être préféré cette pierre
la châtaigne c'était le meilleur à
victoriaville tuto vivent une histoire
lac saint jean qui est le meilleur
[Musique]
chaque région a sa fromagerie préféré je
pensais plus par rapport à notre
attachement à notre région soit
d'origine une nouvelle région le fromage
en grains mais c'est un chaînon on est
toujours autour de cette femme pour cent
de matières grasses on veut toujours
aller chercher les saveurs de beurre de
crème côté lactique mais ce qui est
vraiment le temps de la guerre si on
veut c'est le côté salins c'est le côté
vraiment frais sous la dent
[Musique]
plus dans ce siècle où si je trouve
pourquoi il est plus coûteux et peu
salée aussi le début ça lui qui est dans
la rue vous savez plus allez
c'est drôle à la perception du sel je
pense quoi ce n'est pas parce que le
moins salée des quatre si celui ci ok
les autres
soit à mieux le bleu toi
qu'est ce que ça doit avoir un bon
fromage en grains comme qualité selon un
fonctionnaire et se couche plus
calmement
potok haidari a boudé
substance serait modifié in tient à la
taxe
on voit le pouvoir allait augmenter
notre volume de lait à moindre coût ça
aurait changé un peu la texture crois
pas que ça change vraiment le la à
savoir mais généralement c'est les
fromages un peu plus industrielles qui
ont aussi ajouté ce concentré de les
autres
d'enfants leurs petits
le
bleu le jaune c'est
taux d'humidité donc le sco qui était
bon puis et pas trop salée
mon préféré vie est moins solide
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
préférez celles orange
vous
y fier pour meilleur chez lui n'ont que
deux matches très bien ça ne me ferait
ch twitter.com des six ans warren
particulier les gouttes comme celui du
dépanneur le job comme celui qui achète
le temps et vous aimez 57 av ratures
pièce au au frigo jamais température
pièce le secret de la saveur c'est que
le fait que le fromage est fabriquée ne
jamais été réfrigérée une transporté
directement dans les commerces selon la
loi on perd mais l'eau de pouvoir le
garder température pièce 24 ans après 24
heures on doit le réfrigérer
[Musique]
j'annule vaille moins une mine qui plus
est c'est bon je trouve un peu siècle
vous y allez vous n'abîmez
de bergeron après
quatre
mois de procès mais c'est moi cette
bulle
post alors
l'impression que le meilleur du rétro et
si
jamais ça le port est sûre pour les gens
fassent un deuxième taux
à volonté c'est sans man show répondu
les différences
sont tous très bons même beaucoup alors
qu'elles n'ont pas assez nos buteurs
rennais goûteuse écoutez c'est presque
ex aequo dans le cas de saint guillaume
boivin et rivières mais c'est le fromage
champêtre qui a remporté la palme
aujourd'hui c'est lui qui avait
d'ailleurs à deux reprises remporté le
prix casis comme meilleur fromage en
grains aucun salut par prendre une
troisième fois
[Musique]